the vive just came out this is an
incredible vr headset what makes this
unique is that it is a room scale vr
headset that means rather than just
sitting in front of your desk you
actually get to interact and move around
in a large open space however the only
problem is that there is a wire that
connects you to the computer so what if
we made it wireless sometimes people
will reach out to us and they'll be
things that we don't respond to because
it's just like not what we do and
sometimes there'll be things that are
like
really in line and like really exciting
and like new tech sometimes on those
we'll respond like right away and then
we'll have a phone call with them like a
day or two later and they're like wait
okay so who who are you guys you guys
are like legit right like you're not
just like run off with this tech and
like sell it or like like no like we're
actually genuinely interested in it and
they're like oh okay okay got it got it
i've been using this really awesome
origin pc laptop and it's got a 980m
graphics card in it meaning this thing
is powerful enough to run a vr setup
we're going to take the laptop we're
going to put it into a backpack and we
are going to take the vive and attach a
new battery source to it so that way we
can play vr with no strings attached
unfortunately this laptop the screen
will turn off when it closes so i'm
going to prop it open with a little bit
of cardboard to allow the screen capture
to work and that way you can see what
i'm seeing
tape
open a game space pirate trainer
all right it's working so the vive is
hooked up the controllers are now active
so i'm gonna start screen capping right
now three two one sync
[Music]
and now
let's fit this thing in a backpack
where's my other cardboard so with our
cardboard installed we're now going to
unhook it from the wall and throw it in
the backpack so
let's start off i'm unplugging
the power
divide so the vive is now unpowered it's
lost tracking
but i'm gonna fit it into this backpack
so it's still rolling and recording by
the way it's still screen capping all
this you're going to take
the vive cords put that in there and
we're going to take this wired up 12
volt battery with the same type of
connection shove that in there as well
we are going to power the vive again
usually this is a wall mount adapter but
now we've got our own battery i lost
power less power or less power
no
okay it's reading it
it's black carmichael did it go black
when i unplugged you uh yes
i still don't see anything
let's figure this out
this is the part you cut out
maybe i'll try
is this not giving enough juice at the
moment maybe carmichael you saw it
working right yeah it went black and
went back into the game perfectly and
then you sent me back to blackness sent
you back to blackness all right nothing
yet oh this is such a buzzkill
oh this sucks i should have tried it
made sure it's working before getting in
the backpack
oh my god
all right smooth still smooth all right
here we go upset
[Music]
what's going on
i wonder if that's five
why is the why did the white room look
so good i just lost tracking
no
look the game is running fine the game
is fine
it's the headset what's why does this
work
oh the battery is so [ __ ] low on the
laptop we're waiting
just wait like half an hour if i sit
still for a moment it retracts the
controller and everything that's
happening in the scene is perfect when i
look
that's when it doesn't it's not tracking
the motion of my head it's super smooth
i i'm doing it all
very strange i came down here i tried it
out it was all good everything was
working
why is it not working
nobody knows
next time on the salmon eco vlogs
no
yes no
yes
this is brought up on set